how you feeling buddy you're gonna  become a table tennis player how'd you  feel about that to make sure it they can  fly off wife formally you should not try  this at home I'm bad feeling that  something is gonna go wrong here I think  we're just give it a go  the Beast  [Music]  [Music]  I'm knitting the Sun or I've been  shorted the drone that is getting his  talks about it he seems to know what  he's doing okay so based on the first  interaction with the DOE and I think I'm  gonna need this look at his victory lap  it's gonna happen  I wasn't expecting that I can tell ya  test wanna please  [Music]  nice work  [Music]  I'm supposed to Sarah towards me  [Music]  you know I have the controller I feel  like I'm not in control  [Music]  [Music]  okay  [Music]  [Music]  new plugs did this is how you doing our  own Fannett  that's how you do it  go on overdrive  [Music]  it was a roller but he wasn't the boss  mr. Ramos pretty safe around a man's  mother  yeah well done  [Music]